قالت مراسله الجزيره ان مروحيتين من فرقه
الانقاذ في جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اقل
جنودا مصابين من منطقه جنوب مدينه
غزه وتنضم الينا من غلاف غزه مراسله
الجزيره نجوان سمري نريد تفاصيل اكثر حول
هذه الاصابات وا السياق والمعارك التي
اصيبوا
فيها نعم زين العابدين يعني قبل قليل
رصدنا وكنا معكم على الهواء مباشره
مروحيتين تابعتين لسلاح الجو الاسرائيلي
تحديدا ما يعرف بفرق الانقاذ
669 التي ومنذ بدايه هذه الحرب تتدخل ل
نقل مصابين من الجنود من داخل ارض المعركه
في داخل قطاع غزه الى المستشفيات
الاسرائيليه ولكنها عاده تقل حالات مصابه
بجرو روح خطره لانه في بعض الاحيان ايضا
نرصد اليات عسكريه او اسعافات عسكريه
سيارات اسعاف عسكريه تقل مصابين اخرين
وبالتالي هذه المروحيات تتدخل عندما تكون
الحالات خطيره حالات صعبه تتدخل وتقوم
بنقل الجنود الى المستشفيات الاسرائيليه
المختلفه تحديدا مستشفى سوروكا في مدينه
بئر السبع في النقب وايضا مستشفى برزلاي
في مدينه عسقلان و وهما المستشفيين الاقرب
الى منطقه غلاف غزه وبحسب المعطيات التي
تقدمها هذه المستشفيات فهي ربما
المستشفيات التي استقبلت اكبر عدد من
الجنود منذ بدايه هذه الحرب هذا بالاضافه
الى مستشفيات اخرى في منطقه تل ابيب وفي
منطقه القدس وفقا لقوائم التي تقدمها هذه
المستشفيات عن المصابين قبل قليل لهاتين
المروحتين
انطلق تحديدا من هذه المناطق المحاذيه
لمنطقه جحر الديك جنوب مدينه غزه هذا قصف
مدفعي متجدد ومتواصل عمليا على مناطق
مختلفه في قطاع غزه لكن كنا قبل قليل قد
راينا بدايه نوع من الغطاء الناري الذي
نفذه جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في تلك
المنطقه المحاذيه لمنطقه جحر الديك جنوب
مدينه غزه وقد تكون هذه الاصابات قد وقعت
في مناطق المخيمات الوسطى حيث تدور هناك
ايضا معارك ضاريه في منطقه البريج وفي
منطقه الصيرات والمغازي اي لان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يواصل عملياته في تلك المنطقه
وفي والقصف كذلك بعد ان راينا قصف متواصل
وغطاء ناري متواصل راينا هاتين المروحتين
تنقلان الجنود المصابين وبالتالي قد تكون
القوات على الارض استدعت هذا الغطاء
الناري ايضا لتامين هبوط
ونقل هبوط المروحيه ونقل الجنود المصابين
من خلالها لكن بطبيعه الحال حتى الان لم
يعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي عن المصابين في
الساعات ال
24 ساعه الماضيه يوم امس كان قد اعلن عن
اصابه ل 41 من عناصر في المعارك في غزه
لكنه يحدث هذه المعطيات مره واحده في ال
اليوم لكن في بعض الاحيان وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه والصحف الاسرائيليه تحديدا
صحيفتها ارتس تفصل اكثر عن الاصابات وفقا
للقوائم التي تصدرها ايضا المستشفيات التي
تتعامل مع الاصابات ويتم تحديد نوعيه هذه
الاصابات على سبيل المثال يوم امس عندما
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي عن مقتل احد جنوده
في المعارك في شمال قطاع غزه تحدث عن عدد
مختلف من الاصابات لاحقا قالت صحيفه ارتس
ان 11د جنديا اصيب في تلك الحادثه تحديدا
التي قتل فيها الجندي من بينهم جنديين
اصيبوا بجروح وصفت بال خطيره وما زلنا
نسمع هذا القصف المتواصل زين العابدين على
مواقع مختلفه سواء كان في الاحياء
الشماليه لمدينه غزه ولكن ايضا في مناطق
جنوب مدينه غزه تحديدا المخيمات
الوسطى القصف متواصل و وكنا قد رصدناه
ايضا صباحا في منطقه في المناطق الشماليه
جزء من الانفجارات ايضا التي نسمعها هنا
هي جراء عمليات تفجير تقوم بها قوات
الهندسه التابعه لجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
لمزيد من المباني لتدميرها بشكل كلي كانت
قبل ايام ايام قليله قد قد اصدرت صحيفه
هارت الاسرائيليه تقريرا قالت فيه انه بعد
7 يوما من المعارك في غزه اصيب ما لا يقل
عن
70% او تضرر 70% من منازل قطاع غزه بشكل
جزئي وبشكل كامل وهذا بطبيعه الحال جراء
عمليات القصف من الجو القصف من البحر
وايضا القصف المسعي ولكن ايضا عمليات
التفجير المتعمده التي تقوم بها قوات
الاحتلال ضمن عمليات التدمير الكلي لهذه
المنازل والمنشات زين العابدين ورصدنا ذلك
بالكاميرا من اي جباليا من غزه و من من
الاحياء الحديثه والاحياء القديمه كذلك
شكرا لك نجوان سمري من غلاف غزه وننوي